this week on two sharks one tank five
inventors into the tank in hopes of
catching a killer deal and staking their
claim as the new Big Fish in the child
toy industry but these aren't your
average toys the special needs Rubik's
Cube
no offensive only a fool would
it but just who
[Music]
Millions pushing iconic child toys like
Bill Cosby sleepy time pudding pops R
Kelly's golden stream Super Soaker
playset and the iconic 2023
re-envisioning of the classic He-Man
theyman joining Jordan is Daniel D Kim D
is the Hammerhead investor behind the
node gaming channel he is also the
Visionary behind the iconic kid Tana the
first kid-friendly Katana made entirely
of Japanese steel how will our fresh
batch of inventors fair in these shark
infested waters let's find out on two
sharks one tank
foreign hey what's up guys before we get
into the Goofs up there I want to start
by talking about today's sponsor better
help because they make what we do here
possible better help is the world's
largest therapy service and it's a
hundred percent online and it's also a
very appropriate sponsor because we're
going to get into some sensitive content
here betterhelp has a network of over 30
000 licensed and experienced therapists
who can help you with a wide range of
issues all you have to do to get started
is just answer a few questions about
your needs and preferences in therapy
that way better help can match you with
the right therapist from their Network
then you can talk to your therapist
however you feel comfortable whether
it's via text chat phone or video call
you can message your therapist at any
time and schedule live sessions when
it's convenient for you if your
therapist isn't the right fit for any
reason you can switch to a new therapist
at no additional charge so a few years
ago I sought out to help with my mental
health and I went straight to better
help because I didn't want to have to
deal with a in-person therapist it was a
big step for me and it was much more
convenient and low stakes to speak with
somebody over the Internet so better
help really gave me an outlet and I
found it extremely beneficial to my
brain health and I would encourage
anybody out there to give it a shot so
head on over to betterhelp.com Corridor
crew to get 10 off your first month of
therapy so now that you guys have this
support system this resource we're gonna
hop back into this episode here our
first inventor hopes to dive deep in the
pockets of our sharks with his
Innovative take on pet submersibles you
know I got a lot of hits under my belt
but I'm looking to expand into some new
areas I think these guys will be perfect
Partners to work with here
gentlemen it's a pleasure to be here in
front of you today I got some great
ideas to share with you now you already
know who I am but just in case you know
you need a little refresher we made the
critically acclaimed Lego Passion of the
Christ
and then they'll bring forward their new
groundbreaking concept for the Sharks to
bid on remarkable yeah the game is great
too
so we follow that up with the military
themed Water Park it's really opening
down in Orlando Florida we got great
rides
right after that we got a special Super
Soaker Edition riot police gear wow so
this is fun for the whole family let's
get really take the steam off it's gonna
help kind of bring all of us together
that's a that's a wow and now let's talk
about what I have for you today favorite
family pet favorite family pets favorite
family pet hamster okay right a hamster
is so uncultured right all they do is
they sit around every day just think
about like the boats that you have
sitting at a bottom of your aquarium a
hamster go visit that boat they can get
some culture they can learn a little bit
about history and so we today are
bringing you a special device that does
not exist in the market I can't believe
that this is void that we're just
waiting to be filled it's a hamster
submersible for deep sea ship diving
right so they can go check it out cool
thing is we did our research right
there's an actual submarine out there
that does this and we actually got the
same exact controller from their kit for
our camp good for all ages it's called
Pop Goes the Weasel
and bring it down to the ocean floor I
mean we use a lot of like new cost
saving measures it's kind of like the
way we like do this like we put a lot of
sheets of paper and like glued it and
like you know it seems like it should
work so I feel there's a lot of bad
publicity around submarines these days
how do you how do you think you're gonna
get around that what bad publicity oh
you didn't hear
it's very interesting and a great use
case uh because it's fun and dinner and
I'm curious is there a way to extract
the flattened ham uh flattened ham
um wait flattened ham
right I think more like pressure cooked
oh I like that too I didn't think I'd
meet another Visionary who could see the
meal potential I'll give you
a thousand dollars
for that jacket
[Music]
I don't want the idea at all
thank you thank you so much
yeah yeah God Bless the USA Nico's hopes
of becoming a Titan were crushed in the
Deep Waters of the tank as his
off-the-shelf leather jacket proved more
valuable than his mind major told me to
come to the show just like get some
eyeballs and the stuff I'm doing I don't
really need the money I didn't really
need the jacket either it's pretty warm
out our next hopeful inventor is here to
stake his clan
Your Child's Play you're feeling pretty
good going in today I'm a newcomer but
I've got a lot of great exciting ideas
and I'm gonna do literally whatever it
takes to make a sale sharks
good morning or afternoon whatever time
it is I'm here today representing Austin
corporated child Solutions you may
recognize me from my previous work on my
first wet and wild
a Drunk Driving Experience for kids
because as we know you only get caught
drunk driving if you're bad at drunk
driving and so we got to make sure the
training starts early for this very
strong very strong idea if you don't
recognize that you might recognize me
for my other product the puppy put down
playset yes we taught youths all across
America that their family pets are
mortal and we gave them the choice on
how they want to eventually put that pet
down this broke my son and he was built
back much better so thank you next up we
made a toy that directly responds to the
declining Christianity in the United
States a toy that aims to strike the
fear of God back into our children the
grandma's going to hell playset we need
to strike the fear of God God back into
our children so they start behaving
properly if Grandma's going to hell they
take things pretty seriously down there
so maybe you should behave as well
that's good there's only one way to
motivate children into behaving and
that's the threat of Eternal damnation
[Music]
today I'm going to bring you some new
ideas I'm sure it's safe to say you both
own at least a couple of football teams
no it doesn't and those make you a lot
of money right the whole football
economy is booming but what happens when
kids are scared to play football and we
run out of football players because
concussions can cause lifelong
devastating neurological effects there's
a stigma around concussions and we want
to flip the public perception we want to
make people feel more positively about
concussions and so I bring to you in
cussing the first ever doll that has a
concussion and is living their best life
wow wow they can customize
in a great line of many different
versions so you can rep your favorite
team good any team you want we gotta
Kick custody for it every concussi has a
built-in soundboard into its head that
when you squeeze reveals one of his men
any hilarious and fun catch phrases haha
that tickles my squishy skull
or I love walking it is awesome that I
get to learn it again it's positive or
another one my brain is soup
yummy soup wow two part of the proceeds
go to the NFL or is this all the
proceeds
because whoever's in charge of this
thing that's what I like to hear that's
very nice that was a trick question and
you pass yeah I wrote down I like that
you like wrote down I like that I even
underlined it actually so get yourself a
concussy and give your children the
inspiration to become the next
generation of Great American football
players wow that's dark I'll give you
three million dollars uh for ten percent
that's fair does the other shark have
another offer I like your positive spin
on irreparable damage I'm a big fan of
that rhetoric can we also Branch out
into perhaps the violent outbursts that
we might expect of course suffering
severe concussions we already have plans
to introduce a line of sister products
for the kinkasi called the concussi's
wife oh and it's a smaller doll and are
her quotes perhaps just very forgiving
yes okay that's lovely I see another
shark in the tank there are clearly two
fish but another fish has entered look
at that tie this guy came dressed to
impress entered his prey leaving as a
predator you belong amongst the top
brass and for that reason I'm out
oh I'm threatened so then in that case
I'll be taking your deal oh I forgot
about that yeah yeah it did have a deal
okay all right I am so hot in this
jacket I made a huge mistake Nico I
don't want to deal with this anymore can
you take this back please a thousand
dollars oh good lord okay fine
it's nothing to me so you got yourself a
deal
Satan see you later
that feels all feels off
steals off Austin secured an impressive
and lucrative deal only to Fumble the
bag in the end zone by forgetting to
shake Dee's hand nothing a concussion or
two can't help him erase from his memory
our next inventor has graced the tank
before about six years ago my cat died
from natural causes and he always wanted
me to make a product that could be for
kids only to be eaten alive by our
sharks I'm gonna steal your ideas
your patents won't hold up in court
they're all mine now welcome to the
industry
my therapist and my dad I think were
right I did let my emotions get the
better of me so I got a script this time
I have practiced it I will not be
getting emotional
huh
sharks I wanted to begin today by
showing you a recent release for my
company and uh here here it is typing
literacy rates are at an all-time low
and who better to teach our kids how to
type than someone who apparently they
look up to Andrew Tate teaches typing
here's a screenshot from our typing
screen
we we do think that we've been able to
compile some of the best quotes this is
actually from our speed Challenge and
yes we have over 500 quotes from Andrew
Tate himself these are not AI generated
I repeat he actually said all these
things women can't fight men are
stronger encoding information only
happens with repetition and we believe
that once your child has typed in each
of these quotes three or four times
it will cut to their core during those
crucial developmental years
and now I want to present to you sharks
the toy I'm selling today look there is
a huge Rift in the market today of the
toy industry this is the rift between
pro-lifers and all the rest oh you
notice anything is anything weird the
fact that the toy Market only Services
one side of this debate we would be
missing a whole
golden business opportunity if we
ignored
the other side of this debate
that's where little runts comes in
[Music]
what what this is the world's first
pre-baby doll four children and we have
all sorts of characters and they
represent all of the stages of
development from just a couple cell
divisions old here
and all the way to just a little bit
just a little bit undercooked
yeah there's going to be something for
for every one of your child and we know
that one of our toys will be your
child's new best friend let me ask you a
question yes
do I look like an idiot do you
because I would have to be absolutely
brain dead not to be in love with this
idea let me get in here real quick okay
don't get don't get don't get too
excited I think before you get into bed
with him I think the first question we
need to ask is are these aborted fetuses
or are these yet to be born
that's a very good question I I would
also like to answer that before I get in
bed with you
these are aborted fetuses
you know the face gave it away the face
gave it away that's not the face of a
safe child
that's the face of someone who's seen
the outside too soon there's something
on the back of his paper that says do
not mention the cat why why
do you have to go there dude
just do you want to give me the money
before you slide under those covers I'd
like to float an idea yeah
why don't we take this concept and get
in front of his idea beat him to the
punch I think if you and I go in on this
please we're gonna run with this this is
a great idea we can get in touch with
his people okay I mean maybe we could
work together on this you know 50 50.
you and the fetuses have a lot in common
right now neither of you have a voice
and as such you will be aborted thank
you so much goodbye
Nick had dreams of birthing a company
but was met with the Grim reality that
when you're in the tank it may be your
idea but it's not your choice
I have nothing
our next inventor is hungry for a deal
can he reach out and take it or will
this Hasbro end up as a has been
so just I have like a meeting with
Hasbro in like 20 minutes so and I also
want to level with you sharks I'm a bit
hungover today
same brother I'm hungover because we
were celebrating yet another successful
toy launch at Dean's toys and we've had
massive success with such toys as the
special needs Rubik's Cube
this is a Rubik's Cube that was built
for everyone you don't even need hands
to solve this Rubik's Cube you see we've
also had huge success with our playsets
one of which was the talk Em Down
you see this this place that taught kids
very valuable communication skills we
also have Thomas and the trolley
problems
um which also teaches kids how to
navigate complex ethical dilemmas we
also have dealt with Legacy Brands one
of which was a very popular device for
us the Guan Tamagotchi
God
you know there's lots of fun activities
you can feed them once a day or not
that's also been found to be very
effective
other Legacy brands that we've dealt
with something very close to your heart
the Street Sharks but we wanted to
update them for the Modern Age we wanted
to bring a little bit of relevancy to
their predicament living on the street
and that's where we came up with
unhoused sharks
and they have a dastardly new foe in the
form of Fentanyl
but that's not about today for today we
have a very special toy for you one that
people are gonna be starving for
[Music]
hungry hungry North Koreans
I do love the North Korean idea I am
Korean as well so I relate in a lot of
ways I love how it is strategically made
too deep for the kids to even reach yes
no that's that's the real challenge the
real challenge of the game is that the
food goes straight to the great leader
you know
and we think that challenge will engage
kids in a way that hungry hungry hippos
didn't because those hippos you know
they got some meat on them they're
already you know they're already full
but these kids are starving so yeah like
I said my meetings coming up with Hasbro
so I I was thinking like two million
dollars for 0.01 steak in in uh the idea
I mean I do like the idea that they
can't get away the ankle straps genius
because what fun is the game if there
isn't real hunger hold on he's got a
call I just got off the phone with uh a
friend of mine who works in Hasbro
uh and he said he doesn't even know who
you are it's very interesting who who
was the guy who's the guy Craig Craig
Craig's like super low down I'm meeting
with Greg it's like a secret with me and
Greg that we're meeting up there's no
Greg there's no Greg at Hasbro there's
no Greg
to be very vulnerable with you there's
no meeting with Hasbro and I'm really
desperate right now guys okay I find you
quite boorish hungover
unserious for that reason
I want you more than ever the fact that
you don't care about me at all drives me
wild I just want to get in with you can
I come live with him shake my hand yeah
how about we just bring it in bring it
in all the way it's an honor to do
business and you smell you smell like I
expect yeah can I like that's almost
exactly can I grab the keys to your
place you want to start now okay well
we'll talk about it well I'll see you
I'll see you at your house yeah I don't
remember because that's where I live now
I don't regret it at all Dean Kim Jong
swooned his way into a deal with Jordan
securing himself a hesitant hug and a
place to stay for an indefinite amount
of time
our last inventor is looking to storm
our shark's capital investment but will
he prove fluid enough to navigate such
murky Waters
genius ideas am I right that's what
we're all here for okay countering
cultural narratives I'm ready are you
always yeah great why do dogs suck for
girls
fixed it
finally we have a toy product that's
wildly successful spawning billion
dollar franchises movies toys lunch
boxes everything just for girls oops
really split that up yeah now with the
special edition it's for boys the girl
ones still exists it's like separate but
equal okay the boys should be able to
play with Barbies and we Crack the Code
wow once again countering cultural
whatever I said narratives what's the
worst thing about living in Russia
what's the most dangerous place to be in
Russia I would think Putin no no no but
that's not a place that's a person
prison
the prison hi I think something's holler
multiple stories two-story present water
tower next to the prison okay look
the number one cause of death for
intellectuals in Russia there's a
Windows all right this is a classic take
on the Shoots and Ladders if the game is
simple it's like hey Sally I got a
meeting on the 12th floor today it's
like what's up there I don't know but it
says it's important better go see what
it's about climb the stairs oh whoops
you land on a window boom there goes
your career in your life no I'm gonna
get pushed out a window oh it's scary no
actually it's fun when you first walked
in here I thought I smelled a guppy but
what I see in front of me
is a shark
a shark who maybe wants to do big
business and big business
requires
a bigger hat
you haven't sold me yet son
continue next up countering cultural
narratives toys sometimes they're too
woke sometimes you need toys for the
every man okay sometimes you need to get
yourself activities
you're online you're on Facebook oh
you're reading all this amazing stuff
and like your kids are like shut up Dad
what if there's a way to bond with them
oh These Little Cuties here not only
will steal your heart but they will stop
the steal as well they all first off
they got their guns Second Amendment
it's not a joke First Amendment freedom
of speech look at every single one is
something to say uh we got playsets
different locations we got the pizza
shop everyone's the classic yeah the
classic one so they come in like these
little jail cells and you open them up
to reveal which one you got it's like
we're freeing him and that like you free
him and his knowledge that he knows
about the government's like deep State
conspiracies that's good but wait
because there's one more
and this is the idea I'd like to offer
to you today sharks I know the market
look at these things these things are
called Color Changers have you heard of
them any type of toy that you can change
the colors of by dipping into like
liquid I can't just die over it this is
the market we're getting into here with
our next product the fluid Fighters hmm
a team assembled with the ability to
turn into anything anything a man or a
woman oh my
yeah isn't that crazy wow yeah whatever
the job needs they are there and they
can turn into it and how does the
transformation take place how do they
transform well see that's the real money
maker yeah you get these action figures
that's cool but how do you get people to
keep paying well the only way they
transform is with a bottle of our
patented gender fluid
wow that's good wow this stuff is
incredible like you dunk these
characters in the gender fluid boom
colors change bodies morph there are a
whole new character and we're thinking
this is like awesome for like cartoons
and like kid shows and movies like this
obviously has potential because these
are toys they have like a story and a
narrative behind them I like this I love
how you're hitting both sides of the
narrative I I that's an idea I can get
behind it's strong and I don't put this
hat on for anyone I had a feeling about
you because I don't know if you're
familiar with my history but as the
founder of Dayman
wow you you're the guy behind they man
surprise we have very aligned interests
brother and I think there's a lot of
money to be made here you are a
Visionary I know this Market I've been
there I've navigated the channels I flip
back and forth this feels like only the
natural progression I mean you know this
is all roads lead here you guys seem
like you have a lot of backstory going
on with this uh you still haven't told
us what you want haven't really thought
about this uh you know I was probably
gonna think about maybe let's just say a
cool
three male for half of it
I'll give you your three mil but
I want 69 69 percent
let me do the math okay you got it Bob
you're just gonna because we had I feel
like we had a thing I feel like we
connected and you didn't even give me
enough give me this hat I wore this
Sam proved he can swim in deep Waters
surviving the tank and Landing a
whopping three million dollar deal for a
very funny 69 stake in the company
leaving Jordan caught Hook Line and
stinker Sam Also Rises above the
competition as the only tour inventor to
make any money off his idea maybe next
time these Guppies will have something
even worse to feed the sharks if you
want to see another episode or for us to
take on another industry with our
offensive ideas leave a comment down
below also be sure to check out D's
gaming channel node